I will just stand here and watch
television for hours I love it I love
this TV later in the episode CH throws
one of Michael's many dundy awards at it
cracking the screen and infuriating
Michael in the process that isn't the
last time we see Michael's beloved and
broken miniature TV though the W mounted
Wonder made a cameo a year later tucked
behind another TV in the fifth season
episode Dream Team if that wasn't enough
it shows up yet again nearly two whole
Seasons later in the episode garage sale
sitting plain as day on Michael and
Holly's table it looks like the more
grounded influence of Holly may have
finally convinced Michael to let go of
his prized entertainment possession once
and for all